[Music]
we are here in the channel 8 phone bank
and we're talking about medicare
eligibility brings up a lot of questions
for a lot of people and you have an
opportunity now to get answers to your
questions these good people are here
answering the phones until seven o'clock
tonight so if you have any questions
regarding medicare call
702-650-1101 and they will have answers
for you also with answers is dr gaurav
zarath it took me a second to remember
the last name dr zerath thank you for
being here from southwest medical let's
talk about medicare how does someone
know if they are eligible that's an
excellent question there's much multiple
ways to be eligible for medicare if
you're over the age of 65 that gets you
eligible for medicare and if you're not
at the age of 65 yet certain medical
conditions such as unstaged renal
disease als
medicare has certain very special
eligibility criteria for patients with
these kind of diseases
you also have patients under the age of
65 with certain qualifying disabilities
and if you're already 65 and you're
moving into a new town if you're
relocated las vegas recently that also
gets you eligible to take part in the
open enrollment or any time during the
year to change your plan or
get onto a new medicare advantage plan
all right so if someone is eligible what
are the next steps and how can they be
simplified god that's an excellent
question and the majority of the folks
that can be very complicated process to
pick a medicare advantage plan and it's
very important to break down what your
needs are to start with just write down
the physicians that you see the
providers that you see
your primary care physician to start
with any specialist that you see write
down the medications you take and
whatever your needs are outside of that
um and next step would be to basically
match that with medicare advantage plans
there's so many medicaid advantage plans
out there so you really have to be
careful to pick the one that really
suits your medical needs they can be
tailored to individuals absolutely you
know there's so many medical medicare
advantage plans that
offer different aspects of health care
and if you don't pick the right plan you
may end up getting a plan that doesn't
cover your health care needs
and we certainly have the last step is
to call an insurance broker these are
independent insurance brokers that can
walk you through each step each phase
each part of the medicare plan and
they can certainly assist with picking
the right plan all right dr zerath thank
you again some of our first phone calls
is this early in the afternoon these
folks will be here until seven o'clock
tonight to answer your questions and
we'll have more answers throughout this
show and others throughout the evening